whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up the
California Energy Commission for banning
big-screen TVs unless they conform to
stringent new energy requirements in the
FDA for its war on caffeinated booze
drinks don't tell them Cola has caffeine
in it or regulators might just yank your
rum and coke but there's only one nanny
of the month and this time it's Sal
diCiccio the Phoenix City Councilman got
the ball rolling on a decision that
prevents a local church from feeding the
hungry on church grounds what's the
problem the city says the crossroads
united methodist church was functioning
as a dining hall in an area zoned for
residential use the band hit just in
time for Thanksgiving and by the way it
affects all churches in Phoenix zoned in
residential areas but it's not over just
yet crossroads is appealing the ban and
a hearing is set for December 14 check
back next month for more examples of
busybodies minding your own business
Oh